you
the long day's work begins it's from dawn to dusk
and after that's the way things are on the farm
some run winter go by it maybe darken
the barn but you've got to milk just
the same it may be hot or cold but
the feed has to go to the cattle
a farmer works at a dozen trades
through the day and so does his
wife his sons and his daughters for Bill
Parkinson the long day's work has begun
everybody has to help if you marry a
farmer that's the first thing you learn
and winter go by but the water has to
be pumped in the fire lighted this is
1940 but the farm woman's day is long they
don't complain to women like hazel Parkinson
but they know on an August morning how
hot the stove is going to be at noon
they may not say much about it but they wish you
could just turn a faucet to get your water the way
you can in town they know and their children all
the work that goes into raising food for a nation
milk ringing in the pail quieten clean
fresh milk for the town the city milk
that makes bones and muscles
for the children of a nation
but milk has to be properly cooled or it'll
spoil and sour and that takes bagging arm
milk is the cash crop for a family of seven
here on the Parkinson farm the check from
the dairy means sugar and coffee clothes and
shoes and all the things this earth won't grow
it's good land here not prime but good long
settled land bill Parkinson was born here
in 1889 year his father bought the farm bills
carried it on improved it changed with changing
conditions 205 acres he used to do general farming
but the land got tired now bill his sons cultivate
about 30 acres he rotates corn and oats red clover
and grass now falfa not the best land not Forest
but it has raised five healthy Americans and
Bill and Hazel that's something for land to do
you know per culinary
freshly on roads town
but this HUP day there's something wrong
sour milk good for pigs but not for
human beings it's hard to cool milk
right in August if you haven't the right sort of
pump for equipment you know today was
past modern standards dairy standard
sour milk good for pigs but the milk
check won't be so big this month
eight o'clock time for time and daddy gets
the all south end well there probably goes
to cornfield cooperation on a farm that's
just horse sense a farm is the oldest
cooperative in the world it stays a farm
but it takes on new skills and new ways
washday and the women's work seven people make
a big wash but it's got to be done every week
you can't leave your men folks dirty they
might get used to it heat the water carry
the water pour it in the tub every week just
like cleaning the lamps that's the old way the
hard way yes there is a machine into the
wash but it runs by electricity lamps you
don't have to clean and trimmed Phil but they
run by electricity here on the farm where it's
needed most the electricity is hard to get power
companies want a profit they get it in the city
where people are scrunched up together but the
farms are left in the dark three farms out of
four are left in the dark 75% of all farms in
this big inventive country seems wrong somehow
slow easy steady pitch it up load it ride
we're getting the hay in the hay that means
feed and good milk and cows chewing in the
barn we're taking something from the earth
and we'll give it back to the earth and in
between it will feed American cattle and
American kids the loads part of us and we're
part of the load pitcher up in Miller City
Haughton come but you've got to cut the corn
a kid is about the best crop there is
the wash is up on the line it took till now
only they're still the ironing to be done
roller in roller in and rester yeah that's
a good load a good load a first-class mode
in the shadows turning east and growing
light the light of 70 years ago before
electricity was born the lamp over good
truths in their day and but there are better ones
now good people hard-working people
deserve the best tools man can make
bless this food to this family they have earned it
not by easy tasks but with their strength in their
toil they're wise in the ways of the earth they
are United family how they're tired at the end of
day but they're friendly with each other glad to
see each other's faces they may not say very much
the word home in their heart the things we
cherish most in America are here at this table
while we foster and maintain them
it shall be well with all of us
the long day ends in quietude
but the day's work isn't
lamplight homework the capital of
Illinois is Springfield and the
cattle of Nebraska is Lincoln but the
letters and words to tired eyes blur
and dance on the page she doesn't care so
much about her own eyes but her children's
the knife has to have a good edge
for tomorrow's Moines wouldn't be
so hard if you had a good light on
your work wouldn't be so hard with
power to turn the grindstone they found
that out in the cities in the factories
but one man can change that alone
we get together
why can't you kill them
the knives are cutting the
hi the Sun beats down from the August sky we
built our freedom and strength this way from
Mississippi to Iowa from Oregon to the rocks
of Maine we're building it still together
when we get together we're hard to stop we can
raise a crop and harvest the crop we can get the
power and get the light we can get the things
that we want today with neighbors working the
South same way working together to cut the corn
now they talk it over the country way the slow
cautious decision of the people he liked Christie
about time we got around here well it sure would
helped me out the woman too but the power company
says you can see their lines go cross-country see
them in the sky but they don't bring the power
down to the farm say it costs too much say a
lot of things I'd sure like to light up the
barn in the house too running water Ellen's
always saying if we had running water our company
won't do it but I hear there's a new kind of power
government that's right I hear there's an agency
rural electrification well now how do you go about
it I ain't for it but I'm ready to be convinced
I'm for it if it gets us the power why don't we
get a meeting a meeting and hear about it find
out about it don't have to take it unless we want
but find out about it government power for our
farms one night in the district schoolhouse Bill
Parkinson neighbors get together they listen and
argue and ask questions they speak their mind some
are not easy to convince what's it going to cost
who's gonna run it why is the government doing
it who's going to own the lines the county agent
meets them on their own ground the REA were set up
by the President and the Congress in 1935 to help
farmers to get the power and light at a price they
can afford the Rea loans money at low interest
rates for line construction and where necessary
for generating plants to the co-operative set
up by the farmers in the community there are
no private investors no profit-making you don't
risk any cash yourself except a small membership
fee you get power at Cost when the loan from
the government to your cooperative is paid back
through your electric bills you and your neighbors
will own your own electric system your own lines
in 1935 Rea is born 90% of all American farms
without lighter power the cities are lighted
the country still in the dark lights up 1936
26 REA systems 7,500 farm families like Bill
Parkinson's get lights 1937 lights up there are
122 systems now power and light for 43,000 farm
families lights up for Mississippi and Ohio lights
up north-south-east-west 1939 548 systems four
hundred and thirty-five thousand families and
other users and many more soon to come on the
lines lights up six hundred systems operating
in early nineteen hundred and forty spreading
their wires over 45 states well over half a
million farms schools churches stores and rural
industrial plants getting electric service for the
first time three hundred thousand more expected to
come on these lines and new lines going up almost
everywhere at the rate of five hundred miles a day
the city the place that always had Paul
now wires swing out to the countries
they're stretching out long wires reaching
out where wires never went before there's
a tune as the wind blows through the wire
power for the partisans they're lifting
the poll back in revolutionary days in
this country we used to plant a poll
and call it Liberty Tree this poll has
been a Liberty tree to thousands of farm families
hoist up the transformer it means
kilowatt hours of electricity one
kilowatt hour will do a week's
wash dry and 100 pounds of brain
one kilowatt hour will hoist two tons
of hay kilowatt hours don't get tired
you
bill Parkinson is now a member of
the Belmont Electric Cooperative
I didn't know a stove could look as clean
as that looks as if it would bake good too
Thursday August the 8th 1940s turn Ohio scattered
showers and thunderstorms tonight and Friday
cooler Friday afternoon and night much cooler
and Southwest portions of the state here's your
weather forecast the united states weather
electricity means running water on the farm
you can throw the old pump handle away this
pump works all the time for a few cents a day
clean ice no worry about
these souring spoiling summer
many farmers read their own meters
I've made a sound quiz chief in the
city but in a cooperative you tried to
cheat you'd only be cheating yourself
fresh milk clean milk for the town cooled
by the running water your returns from the
dairy no more milk that should have
fed the children gone to the pigs
c'mon fellas we got an electric mama now
a turn of the hand means drinking water for
the horses a turn of the hand
instead of minutes at the pump
a big weeks wash but it won't take
any woman's back no bending over the
scrub board no rubbing or scrubbing
while your arms and fingers ache
here is the first thing women
ask for after light itself if
you have ever ironed for an hour you'll
know why an electric iron may not look
important to a man but it lightens
one whole day's burden for a woman
they say a lady in Missouri even taught
her ringer how to shell peas I won't ask
for an affidavit on that but she says it's true
power it cost better living we've got the
power from the High Line's now it'll help
us out through night and day we've gotten
youtubes for the old toil we learn their
ways and set them to work set them to work
to help us all neighbors working together we
hired the money and brought the wire it's our
own power in our own light it will belong to
all of us all of us here together it's a friendly
sound when the motor of words the friendly sight
from the lights go on it's the light and power
we've never had but we've got it now together
and on day ends things will be easier now